Ascar, Alexa,
believes that they will deceive everyone,
there are 2 things, no,
that I did not take Capacoro Majarrogan,
in relation to budgets,
and that I did not take Reca,
the generality,
pugués,
Fe de emna,
ah, to, for iranda,
go to the project or put it through,
and are going to be doubts,
lies,
because now we know that there had to be,
that the cording has now been renewed
sun to buy the Terrence,
30 minutes,
the Crown advances to the psc,
and, as it was, Josh Buffett,
Boudy,
Calised,
I was able to GO to Tura,
to the project,
harrock ardan and gutunangain,
states the citizenry.
And he believes scholtens,
on sadon Atlas Road,
not that one, not the month,
is 1 project which is
negative for the future of the Catalan economy.
But to me,
that month is Cara,
a,
believes that he will fool Tori otote and in quartz,
what U.S.
citizens do know,
is that what kinds of things,
if the commons bring sufficient strength
in the generality's own coward,
to prevent them from passing,
we will inhabit them,
that here Burgue and transparency,
me that you are with caquibulgui,
cassigui, of course,
rebullo al jarroquibulgui bets on 1 model
different,
zabkala bag and Jessica olvia,
who is the Seva candidate,
we do not in yugat Mai,
to open the door,
that there are types of projects,
and that there are plenty of them,
there is 1 such lie promoter,
oh ma, well yes, now,
which is deeply critical